les objectif c'est d'apporter un soutien
un accompagnement aux jeunes qui sont en
difficulté à la rentrée c'est en général
une problématique rencontrée chaque
année mais c'est encore plus difficile
pour certains avec la crise actuelle
[Musique]
oui c'est compliqué parce que les
entreprises ont peu de visibilité sur
sur leurs possibilités d'embauché ont
elles mêmes des difficultés à maintenir
leur équipe en place donc intégrer des
jeunes
qu'ils sortent des études ou qui
recherchent une alternance à un stage
c'est un petit peu compliqué pour elle
alors sur ce forum il y aura 45 stands
avec 35 recruteurs et parmi ces
recruteurs y aura donc des possibilités
en termes d'alternance d'emplois de
stages et de service civique
il y aura également mur d'offres et des
structures d'accompagnement et
d'information pour les jeunes pour que
faire connaître l'accompagnant quelles
preuves proposés aux jeunes et aussi
cerné un petit peu plus un projet qui
pourrait les aiguilles et s'ils sont
complètement perdus dans leurs leurs
perspectives de d'insertion on va dire